mario has a fish tank that is a right
rectangular prism with base 15.6
centimeters
by 7.2 centimeters so let's try to
imagine that so it's a right rectangular
prism it's a fish tank let me actually
do it in blue so it
one of the dimensions that's not blue
that's orange
one of the dimensions is 15
15.6 centimeters
15.6 centimeters and then the other
dimension of the base
is
7.27 7.2 centimeters
7.2 centimeters so this is the base
right over here
so let me draw this
try to put some perspective in there
and of course it is a right rectangular
prism this fish tank that mario has
so it looks something like this
so this is his fish tank
try to draw it as neatly as i can so
that's the top of the fish tank
just like that
i think this does a decent
respectable job of what this fish tank
might look like and let me erase this
thing right over here and there we go
there is mario's fish tank
there is his fish tank and we can even
make it look like glass there you go
that looks nice
all right the bottom of the tank is
filled with marbles and the tank is then
filled with water to a height of 6.4
centimeters
so the water is filled to a height of
6.4 centimeters so this is the water
when it's all filled up
6.4 centimeters
so let's draw that
and i'll make the water
well
maybe i should have made it a little
more blue than this but this gives you
the picture
so the height of the water right over
here actually let me do that in the blue
color
the height of the water right over here
is 6.4
6.4 centimeters
so that means that the distance from the
bottom of the tank to the top of not the
tank but to the top of the water is 6.4
centimeters
6.4
centimeters
fair enough so that's the top of the
water
when the marbles were removed and it
started off with some marbles in on the
bottom they don't tell us how many
marbles when the marbles are removed the
water level drops to a height of 5.9
centimeters so when they're removed the
water level drops by a little bit to 5.9
centimeters
5.9 centimeters so it drops
it drops to five point
it drops to 5.9 from 6.4
to 5.9 centimeters
what is the volume of the water
displaced by the marbles
so when you took the marbles out the
water dropped from 6.4 so it dropped
from 6.4 centimeters
centimeters down to 5.9 centimeters 5.9
centimeters so how much did it drop
well it dropped 0.5 centimeters so it
dropped
it dropped
0.5
centimeters so what does that tell us
about the volume of water displaced by
the marbles well the volume of water
displaced by the marbles must be the
amount of that must be equivalent to
this volume
this volume of this i guess this i guess
this is another rectangular prism that
is the same where the top area is the
same as the base of this water tank and
then the height is the height of the
water drop when you put the marbles in
it takes up more volume it pushes the
water up by that amount by that volume
when you take it out then that wat that
volume gets replaced with the water down
here and then that volume goes back down
the water level goes down to 5.9
centimeters so essentially trying to
find the volume of
of a rectangular prism
that is
that is
equal to so it's going to be 15.6 by 7.2
by 0.5 and i haven't drawn it to scale
yet but i want to see all of the
measurements so it's going to be 15.6
centimeters
in this direction it's going to be 7.2
centimeters in this direction and it's
going to be 0.5 centimeters high 0.5
centimeters high
so we know how to find volume we just
multiply the length times the width
times the height
so the volume in centimeter cubed and
once again we're multiplying centimeters
times centimeters times centimeters so
it's going to be centimeters cubed is
going to be so let me write this down
the volume
is going to be 15.6
times 7.2
times
0.5 that's going to be in centimeters
cubed or cubic centimeters i guess we
could call them
well let's first multiply 7.2 times 0.5
we can do that in our head this part
right over here is going to be 3.6
essentially just half of 7.2 so then
this becomes 15.6
times 3.6 so let me just multiply that
over here
so
15.6
times
3.6 so i'll ignore the decimals for a
second
6 times 6 is 36
5 times 6 is 30 plus 3 is 33
1 times 6 is 6 plus 3 is 9.
and then
let's place a 0 here we're down in the
ones place but i'm ignoring the decimals
for now three times six is
eighteen
three times five is fifteen plus one is
sixteen
three times one is three plus one is
four
and then we get 6 3 plus 8 is 11
16
5.
now if this was 156 times 36 this would
be 5 616 but it's not we have two
numbers to the right of the decimal
point 1 2 so it's going to be 56.16
so the volume
the volume we deserve a drum roll now is
56.16
cubic
cubic centimeters